hello internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report it is september 12
2022 we are live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv if you have not
subscribed uh please do so and tap that
notification bell so you might just
might get our videos uh you may have
noticed that we did not do a cold open
today there is a reason for that
obviously yesterday sunday was the
anniversary of the 21st anniversary of
the 9 11 attacks and really how our
whole history and future changed on that
day
and over the weekend as i was thinking
about it
and talking to some friends and family
especially yesterday
i realized that we didn't do anything on
the show about it earlier in the week
and i wanted to do something today
related to 911
a little bit on the personal side a
little bit on the political side but
then sort of blend it with what i've
been trying to do with the show lately
which is that we have to get out of this
descent to hell that we all seem to be
on this endless polarization this you're
a nazi you're a fascist like are we
gonna rip this thing apart are we gonna
just give up you know the most precious
experiment in human freedom that has
ever existed so that's kind of what i
want to do
today you know so real quick i want to
just mention and some of you have heard
me either say parts of this before on
the show i've mentioned it here or there
or i wrote about it a little bit in the
first book don't burn this book but i
lived in new york city during 9 11. i
was
basically fresh out of college first
couple years i was doing stand-up at
night i was working all sorts of odd
jobs as a waiter and a bartender and i
just and i stood on street corners
handing out tickets all sorts of crazy
stuff but i lived on 90th and first
which is the upper east side so in some
ways that's sort of the polar opposite
of uh of downtown where the towers were
obviously i was on the upper east and
they're far obviously far downtown and
i lived 90 of the first was basically a
block away from the from the mayor's
mansion
and rudy giuliani obviously was the
mayor at the time and because i was
doing all these odd jobs i didn't have
to wake up first thing in the morning
and i woke up that morning because my
phone kept ringing and it was my dad who
worked in midtown at the time around
times square area uh and he had seen
uh the second plane hit because
obviously the first plane hit then there
was you know a little bit of time
between he had seen it from his office
he he had a great office in times square
um and then once the second plane hit
obviously everyone knew there was an
attack so that's what i woke up to that
day and then
you know without without belaboring the
entire point just the weeks of of
craziness in new york city all of us
glued to our tvs i had several friends
that couldn't get out of new of new york
to get home to either westchester long
island jersey et cetera so i had friends
that were staying with me for days the
trains weren't working uh what my i'll
tell you one little story but some of my
memories include uh i remember walking
out to first avenue because i was like
oh man i better get some stuff for the
house like we didn't remember at that
time we didn't know they were they were
saying there's all these other planes
like it felt like society was just
collapsing
and i walked outside and it was probably
about an hour later and you could
already smell the soot and the debris
and all of the stuff in the air probably
toxic stuff in there and i'm talking i
was in the polar opposite part of new
york city and i remember walking down i
was just going to go to a little bodega
get water or whatever and i remember
seeing literally thousands of people
just walking down first avenue well
technically they were walking up
walking up first avenue that's one of
the images that really strikes me and uh
and it was my dad couldn't get out of
the city he had he and some of his
co-workers actually stayed at my my
grandma's apartment who lived in
manhattan and all the stories that you
all know i i've
fortunately at firsthand didn't know
anyone that that died in the twin towers
which is or on the day
which is kind of amazing but i have a
lot of friends that new people and
family members that new people but one
story that i want to tell you because i
think it'll get to what i want to get to
today which is like how do we how do we
bring this thing back together because
after 9 11 we kind of were together and
maybe it was fake to some degree and
something like that um but there is we
can't keep doing this thing forever this
endless like mutually assured
destruction that we're doing all the
time so it was about two weeks after 9
11 and i had been in my apartment just
staying in there watching cnn all you
know all the time that's all anyone was
doing nobody really was going to work
you know it was very eerie in the city
it still smelled like there you know the
air wasn't clean all of that stuff and
finally one day i was like i have to get
out i was like let me just grab my
basketball i'm going to go over
to the basketball courts by the mayor's
mansion about a block away
and i go out there and play and there
were a couple guys out there you know we
just kind of like pulled together this
pickup game and we're playing and we
were like five minutes into the game and
you know i don't think anyone knew each
other like it was just like a bunch of
people that showed up at the court and
were playing and one guy fouled another
guy really hard like kind of elbowed him
and they got into each other's face like
exploded into each other's face like
everyone had all this pent up
frustration and anger and pain and fear
and all this stuff they got into each
other's face this sounds like a movie
but this is exactly what happened
they're screaming at each other
and then i kid you not they both began
crying at the exact same time
crying crying and then everyone on the
court kind of we all kind of got it and
we let it go and then and then we kept
playing after that nobody really said
anything about anything or whatever
but that feeling that feeling like can
we get back to a little of that i think
there is a way actually uh and that's
what i'm gonna be focusing on today and
i think is probably what i'll be trying
to focus on uh going forward can we find
something that is a sane middle again
can we put away some of the hatred and
all of that stuff i know if you're
watching this that you're willing to do
it and and that
then begs the question like well okay if
you're willing to do it but the other
side isn't what do we do and i think
there maybe are ways that we can change
tactics and things so that's going to be
the focus uh today real quick guys let
me talk to you about express
vpn uh you know watching netflix without
using expressvpn is like going to a
casino and only being able to play on
this on the slot machines why limit
yourself like that the big money is
somewhere else netflix has different
content libraries for every country
netflix has thousands of shows but
without a vpn you only get access to a
fraction of that based on your location
let's change let's you change your
online location control where you want
netflix or other streaming websites to
think you're located that's what
expressvpn does while using expressvpn
i've been watching all sorts of stuff at
the moment what am i i'm watching cobra
kai season 5 which i think they have
everywhere
you just open the app you select united
states as your country you tap one
button to connect and then you refresh
your page and whatever you want to see
is there why choose expressvpn over
other competitors you can gain access to
thousands of new shows thanks to their
servers in 94 different countries and
you can stream in hd with zero buffering
so be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only getting
access to a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
ruben that's expressvpn.com
ruben okay so i want to just dive into a
little bit
of 911 and what it was like back then
and sort of where we are at the moment
uh ami horowitz put together he's a
documentarian he put together a great
documentary that's over at the daily
wire
site i want to show you just about a
minute of it that just the beginning
minute because i think it'll sort of
frame a little bit of what i want to do
today
[Music]
what was your 9 11 experience
i saw some a lot of paper in the air and
i turned my head and looked upward
911 was a seminal event in american
history
this just in you were looking at
obviously a very disturbing live shot
there that is the world trade center and
we have unconfirmed reports this morning
that a plane has crashed into one of the
towers of the world trade center
where were you when on 11
what was your experience
these were among the most frequently
asked questions of that generation
and everyone had their story
it changed our relationship with the
world and how we view it
it's hard to believe that it's been 20
years and how much has changed in this
country
some for the good
and some
not so good
it does feel like an awful lot has
changed back then um
a couple days after 9 11 i think it was
maybe three days after as as the
buildings were still burning as they
were still trying to pull people out of
the wreckage and all that
george w bush gave his famous 911
bullhorn speech which probably was the
best moment of his entire presidency
i want you all to know
that america today
america today
is on bended knee
in prayer for the people whose lives
were lost here
for the workers who work here
for the families who more this nation
stands with the good people of new york
city
and new jersey and connecticut
as we mourn the laws
of thousands of our citizens
i can hear you
i can hear you the rest of the world
hears you
and the people
and the people who knock these buildings
down
will hear all of us soon
[Applause]
man chills up my spine even though i've
seen that probably 500 times um that
feeling
that feeling of we're in this thing
together it doesn't matter where you're
from what you look like all of that
stuff america that's what he's talking
about there
that's i think the spirit that we got to
get back to here you may remember that
after 9 11 then of course everything uh
was delayed or canceled public events
all sorts of stuff the world series was
held basically two months later there
was an incredible
moment during the baseball playoffs sami
sosa on the chicago cubs hitting a home
run
freo pitch swing and a hard drive belt
to deep turn right
back toward the track hit the wall it
is salsa hits it under the basket and
he's got old glory too
and how about the handoff from billy
williams and he carries all glory on the
grand tour for home run number 59.
you're not going to believe it guys
there were democrats republicans
independents libertarians progressives
all sorts of people in the audience
there in the in the stands and nobody
cared what their differences were and i
don't think anyone in those stands cared
what anyone's sexuality was or color of
their skin or anything else so then
yesterday as we were looking through
some of this stuff
i saw this video this is uh well this is
donald trump a day or two after the
attacks you walked around and as you saw
the piles of rubble
there are thousands of families out
there
who are hoping that someone might be in
a pocket somewhere still alive still
breathing waiting to be dug up as you
assessed that damage from your
perspective do you believe that's
possible well i would certainly not want
to be the one to say it's not possible
certainly it's uh
it's a tough situation but you can't
give up hope because there's always hope
i mean the five men i'm sure their
families thought that they probably were
gone and now they walk in the door a
couple of them walked away after they
were dug out so there probably are some
more people in there and therefore you
can't give up hope
you can't give up hope
ain't it the truth whether you're
talking about
literally people buried under rubble or
whatever is going on right now you gotta
have hope so now i wanna sort of
contrast that with a little bit of
what's going on with our political
rhetoric today so obviously you know
what was it about eight nine days ago
there was that really just absolutely
insane joe biden speech once again
demonizing half the country really the
horrific optics of you know the sort of
nazi imagery that he was standing behind
all of that kind of stuff well then
hillary clinton uh was do making the
rounds this weekend on a bunch of shows
sort of talking about 911 but then also
talking about just other issues and you
know a whole bunch of other stuff
but listen to her basically tying 911
extremism into today's political climate
and and i show you this as something
this is what we're going to have to
fight
i feel
grateful
that
we were able to come together as a
country at that really terrible time we
put aside differences i wish we could
find ways of doing that again
we rebuilt new york
we have done our best to take care of
the
families that lost so much on that
terrible day
and we have also i think
been reminded
about
how important it is uh to try to
deal with extremism of any kind uh
especially when it uses violence to try
to achieve political and ideological uh
goals
so
i'm one who thinks that
there are lessons still to be learned
from what happened to us on 9 11 that we
should be very aware of uh during this
time in our country and the world's
history
so it's interesting because this is the
sort of double speak that i'm always
warning you guys about and i think they
really do do it by design and i'm
mentioning this not to slam her but to
just sort of expose it so then we can
figure out how to react to this stuff a
little bit better because on one hand
she's saying we came together afterwards
and we you know we shouldn't be
demonizing people and we used to be able
to put aside differences
this is the same person who when she was
running for president just a couple
years ago basically called half the
country deplorables who still runs
around calling people fascists and
all the rest of the stuff and of course
she's doing that on news shows that
constantly are demonizing one side and
hiding the bad stuff about the other
side when she talks about extremism of
of any kind so you see what she did
there she's talking about violent
extremism and it's very obvious what her
move was her move was oh there was this
horrific thing that happened 21 years
ago
9 11. but now she's linking it to what
she's trying to do is link it to january
6th and that somehow the republicans are
the ones that are violent and that are
fascistic and all of these things and
it's like well actually hillary
um it was the democrats and antifa and
black lives matter and all you guys that
were rampaging through our cities so
there is something to be said about
political extremism but perhaps you
should be the one being lectured not
giving the lecture but i don't bring
this up to just add fuel to the fire of
all that i bring it up again because we
gotta figure out a way to get around
this stuff and i do think that it is
possible i've got some ideas which i'll
get to in just a moment
let me talk to you guys about liquid iv
real quick you know the hot summer
months here in miami florida david and i
often need to be proactive about keeping
our bodies fueled and hydrated making
hydration a priority can help us feel
healthier in our everyday lives one
stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone plus
liquid iv products taste great with 10
refreshing flavors like concord grape
lemon lime pina colada and tropical
punch sounds like summer doesn't it i
use liquid iv this weekend after going
out to dinner and i can tell you i feel
pretty pretty pretty good pina colada is
my personal favorite grab your liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidity.com
and use code ruben at checkout that's
anything
uh you want on the site for 25 off and
you'll get better hydration today using
promo code ruben at liquid iv.com
okay so let's go back
to that division that i was talking
about because it's there
the framework that i think the
mainstream media and the democrats and
big tech everyone wants you to think
that the division in america is only
here and it's only here because of trump
and ultra magga and the republicans and
the fascists and all of this stuff and
it's like well maybe it's not exactly
that maybe there were a set of people
who were saying really bad things about
half the country for quite some time and
not enough of us called it out right
when we should have
this is hillary clinton in 2016. i think
you'll remember this one be grossly
generalistic
you can put
half of trump supporters into what i
call the basket of deplorables
right
the racist sexist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic you name it
really think about that moment for just
a second i know this is old but what is
old is new again right like really think
about that what she's saying there is
half of trump's people so
let's go on the assumption last time
trump ran they say he got 74 million
votes uh so let's just take half of that
number i understand that that was a
little bit later but let's let's just
say we should talk about 30 million
people right or how many votes did trump
get the first time around can we grab
that but let's just say it's about 30
million people what are you saying to 30
million people you're saying that
they're maybe you're racist you're a
bigot you're a sexist you're a homophobe
you're an islamophobe you're a
transphobic you should be pushed to the
margins of society and then how will
people react when they see the powerful
people talking to them
like that talking about them like that
well
they might become more extreme now i
don't think we have 30 million racist
bigot homophobe transphobic extremists
in the united states but i think we have
we have some of those people it's a
small amount of people and it's part of
the human condition being bigoted it
ain't good uh but that's why we have to
you know use better ideas to convince
people that uh bigotry is not a good
thing uh but when she says this what
she's basically doing is what joe biden
is doing now what joe biden is doing in
that speech now these ultra mega
republicans they're not regular
republicans they're these evil horrible
things and this is not a
it might be a i was going to say it's
not a winning strategy it might be a
winning strategy right joe biden is
president so it might be a winning
strategy donald trump is not president
but it is not a strategy if you want to
have a healthy society that is going to
be able to continue and flourish if
every time a bunch of people who maybe
think a little bit different or want a
little less government or just aren't on
the bandwagon of whatever the spirit of
the day is supposed to tell them to do
uh if you push those people to the
margins you got a real problem and then
of course what always comes with this is
how media and culture
and all these things they sort of
collide together so if you're a democrat
you can say the worst sorts of things
about people you can you can actually
call for violence we've shown you videos
many times maxine waters and others
calling for violence and lori lightfoot
and you know wishing thomas clarence
thomas would die like all sorts of stuff
right you're allowed to do it if you're
a democrat because there's democrat
privilege and the media will keep
putting you on tv shows and say nice
things about you
and if you're a republican you can't do
that well then hillary clinton went with
her daughter chelsea clinton
they went on
andy cohen's bravo show i can't believe
the show still exists anymore that this
guy's still doing this but he's got this
show it's mostly about reality tv but he
brought on
hillary and chelsea to just sort of
launder more of the nonsense right you
don't bring on any republicans you don't
bring on any conservatives you bring on
the supposed good guys oh and before i
throw to the clip trump got 61 million
votes the first time around so she was
basically i said 30. she was talking
about 30 million people anyway here is
hillary clinton and chelsea clinton on
andy cohen's show on bravo i'm going to
show you some celebrities hillary
clinton say the first question you would
want to ask each one if they were on
guts oh okay
okay so starting with
melania trump what's your first question
um how's your summer going okay
next question
um clarence thomas
sorry i'm sorry don't you want to retire
okay so i'm not telling you that
anything that they did there was that
horrible right i'm really not but i'm
showing you like they just get on these
tv shows and they just seem like the
good guys
right they just seem like the good guys
maybe andy cohen should sit down with
donald trump and uh ivanka trump ivanka
used to be friends with chelsea i don't
think chelsea's friends with her anymore
like
maybe you could do that but this is how
the machine just goes and goes by it's
sort of by default the factory settings
here are that oh here's a fun reality tv
talk show and here's this woman and her
daughter like chelsea like why do we
should anyone care about chelsea i don't
think we should um but what they're
doing there is they're they're pushing
divisive rhetoric on non-political
people i don't think that the average
person who watches andy cohen's show and
what are they watching what do they have
on bravo real housewives of
psychotown or like you know crazy botox
botox lips of hoboken or whatever they
have it's like that's what he talks
about on there but then you bring on
these people and it's like oh here are
the good political people so that when
these people go vote who aren't
political they're just by default be
democrats and
that actually is divisive that actually
because it's it's a subtle divisiveness
uh but sometimes the divisiveness is way
less subtle and uh
i told you guys on friday that charlie
crist charlie crist is the guy running
against ron desantis here in florida
charlie crist was a republican his whole
life it didn't work out well for him so
now he's a democrat he stands for
nothing he is just like an empty
suit like the worst sort of politician
you can possibly imagine nobody supports
him but the media keeps putting him on
because he's anthony desantis okay well
he went on the view on friday and i
promised you on friday that we would
cover some of it today it's pretty good
stuff we'll get to it in one second let
me just talk to you about real estate
real estate agents i trust you guys know
that buying or selling a home is already
one of the most stressful things you can
do and it can be way worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to agents before inviting them
to join their network and here's a big
one they only work with full-time pros
no part-time or inexperienced agents
they make the introduction then follow
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records are the best sellers
in their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to real estate agents
itrust.com today and provide them with
some basic info their team will contact
you to make an introduction to a
preferred agent in your town you move to
florida and you live happily ever after
but speaking of someone living in
florida who's not very happy about it so
this guy charlie crist he's just nothing
when you talk about just these nothing
people who become democrats the media
puts them on the shows and they're
supposed to be the good guys he went on
the view on friday before we get though
to charlie on the view you know they do
their hot topics on the view and connor
do we have the warning that we're going
to show you thank you very much
we have the content advisory for you
right down below you can see that this
is sunny hostin who may be
i'm trying to be nice today i'm trying
not to be divisive what can i say what
can i say
she she may
she's she's not a great person
sonny hostan is not a great
person so um
well here's sonny austin if you're
saying all desantis supporters have hate
in their heart that's not going to win
people to your side this is the problem
melissa
60 to 70 percent
of republicans i'm not even saying mega
republicans or this republic 60 to 70
percent of republicans believe that
donald trump is the leader of their
party and so if you are saying that he
is a fascist what are they if you are
saying that he is a white supremacist
what are they if you are saying that he
is a racist what are they because if you
follow someone that has hate in their
heart and i believe that he does then
you are complicit in that and you don't
get
a pass on
oh god and then the seals the clapping
seals now first off
60 to 70 percent of republicans may view
donald trump as the leader of the party
that's something that the republicans
have to figure out is donald trump the
leader of the party is ron desantis the
leader of the party is there someone
else that's an interesting debate to
have but you see how quickly you could
just flip her logic against her like joe
biden i think is mentally compromised i
think he's the worst sort of career
politician i don't think he knows what
he believes i think he reads all sorts
of awful speeches that are inherently
racist and sexist and all sorts of stuff
does that make everyone who supports him
all the worse things in the world but
that's what she's trying to do also just
to be clear donald trump is not a
fascist the democrats have far more
fascistic policies than the republicans
generally what republicans want is to
separate government and business fascism
is combining those things what the
democrats have brought in through all of
these woke corporations through all of
the vaccine mandates and you're going to
get fired from your job if you don't
take an injection those are far closer
to fascist ideas
granted i know that sonny doesn't know
what fascism is but i'm just putting it
out there uh that if you believe that
donald trump is a white supremacist yes
the guy who gave the speech at the state
of the union talking about lowest
all-time black unemployment who did more
on criminal justice reform than any
president in modern times uh and who all
of the congressional black caucus sat
there like this when he was talking
about it he's the white supremacist and
then of course she also calls him a
racist uh okay usual stuff
then on friday and again we're going to
get to this charlie cris guy in a minute
here's more from sunny can you put the
warning up again and i should be
drinking today
uh this woman she's just extraordinary
so there was a carnegie mellon
university professor her name is ujja
anya
and she when the queen of england passed
away a couple days ago uh she put up a
really horrific tweet about it uh and
then carnegie mellon university put out
a statement saying that they don't you
know that she doesn't represent their
views now it's sort of hilarious in a
way as several people pointed out online
it's like well you let this woman teach
all these young people for years so she
can teach all these horrible ideas but
when she tweets out a bad idea now we
better say something about it anyway
surprise surprise sunny defended her
what did he say he said she
she said a thieving raping genocide
empire is finally dying may her pain be
excruciating it was a thieving raping
genocidal um but i think but
twitter took that tweet down because it
violated its policies of of wishing
okay so first off she doesn't even know
if it's a he or she like she just
doesn't know what she's talking about
she's unprepared and everyone's the
worst of all things and that she can so
glibly yes it's just that the british
empire was just thieving and raping and
genocidal and it's like you know what
there were literally literally
millions of messages sent from some of
those places that uh people would say
the uk dominated and destroyed and you
know all of those things say india say
parts of africa in support of the queen
it's not to defend the empire and it's
not to defend people going outside of
their borders and imposing their wills
on people and any of those things this
was a woman
this is a woman who lived with really
incredible dignity her entire life who
was not supposed to be queen at the age
that she became it i mean it's an
absolutely incredible story uh the
abdication of the throne and her
stepping into these responsibilities and
she lived with grace and decency and we
can all talk about whether a monarchy is
worth it or not and in some ways i think
right now we're seeing proof that
monarchies have some value because they
last over time instead of just the the
crazed sort of politicking of the day
but okay putting all of that aside it's
just so incredible it's someone likes
sonny yes yes she's genocidal and then
the monarch and it's all just evil
okay fine now here is this guy charlie
crist and charlie crist has no support
in the state of florida he just has no
support but the media wants you to think
he has support and they will do anything
obviously to stop ron desantis because
ron desantis stands for freedom and you
guys know all about that so they bring
charlie crist on and what's hilarious is
so anna navarro now is going to ask
charlie a couple questions here anna
navarro it turned out it was exposed uh
by this guy brandon leslie who uh who
i've met a couple times good guy he
found a whole bunch of tweets of anna
navarro's that he tweeted out at about
10 am right before the view went live of
her saying the worst possible things
about charlie crist so then that started
going viral so anna felt that she had to
really push charlie chris this is just
great james you've been in 16 elections
in the last three decades and that time
you've gone from a staunch republican to
an independent to a democrat your own
words charlie have come back to haunt
you have been used against you what
would you say to skeptics like me who
think you've changed parties because
you're a political mercenary and it was
out of out of convenience how should we
trust you how do you convince me i
changed parties because my party changed
you know it started with the rise of the
tea party back in 09 and 2010
and it really has metastasized since
then and you know i just couldn't
stomach it anymore to see
how you know not all republicans i don't
want to paint too broad a brush here
because there's a lot of good
republicans in florida and in our
country
and uh what i understand though is that
the party has changed dramatically from
what it was
when i was a republican and and what
i've seen is that it's so uh
anti-minority frankly this governor is
making it harder for african americans
to vote in my state
making it harder for senior citizens
like my 90 year old father my 87 year
old mother male in balloting is more
difficult in florida now
okay so you can really just he just
reeks of like they know desantis is
going to crush it they had to put up
somebody so you just find some career
politician loser who will take any
position on absolutely anything but of
course the
the the party change not him and the tea
party really was the thing that pushed
him over the edge the tea party which
wanted lower taxes the tea party which
wanted states rights
um you know he's talking about them
becoming anti-minority it's like it's
just so not true do you know how many
cubans and hondurans and all sorts of
people i meet here in florida every day
who absolutely love ron desantis and
they believe in borders and all of these
things so he's just he's just sort of
nothing he the guy is just nothing this
you know what i'm going to make a
commitment on the show today barring
something so cataclysmic so off the
record
uh i am never going to talk about
charlie crist again the election
obviously isn't about what is it now
little less than two months i'm not
going to talk about this guy again
because it's by talk i'm just giving
oxygen to nonsense it's just silliness
but i had to do this because i want it
just it's just about showing you how the
machine fakes these people um
here's more about new newly minted
republican charlie crist uh on some of
joe biden's recent comments
what do you think about the president
calling millions of americans
semi-fascist
listen he's got to express and be honest
about what he feels in his heart and his
soul and i think that's probably exactly
what he did
it's just so perfect i mean he has no
heart and soul you have no heart and
soul you will say anything to get
elected and be part of any party and
everything else uh you know charlie
crist also if you want to
google this i don't know why more people
aren't bringing it up and it doesn't
really matter in some case in some ways
but there was a documentary about 15
years ago called outrage and it was all
about closeted gay republicans who were
secretly gay and having relations with
other people of the same sex and then
voting the opposite way most of the
documentary is about charlie crist
because he used to be according to this
documentary and it was it was a fairly
mainstream documentary uh he used to be
a republican and i guess he used to be
gay now he gets a new wife every couple
years so he just i think he just got
engaged again because it's all theater
and nonsense uh anyway what else does
charlie chris think about the people in
florida that maybe aren't fully on board
with him well listen to this one
those who support the governor should
stay with them and vote for him and i
don't want your vote
if you have that hate in your heart keep
it there
i want the vote of the people of florida
who care about our state good democrats
good independence good republicans unify
with this ticket
[Music]
unify after he demeans and belittles
half of the people more than half
probably 70
of the people in florida okay so what is
the point of all of this why am i
linking charlie crist
and watching a bravo tv show with 9 11
and all of these things i'm trying to
show you that the machine is just going
to it's never going to stop it's never
going to stop trying to tear us apart
it's never going to stop elevating
people who will say one thing and do the
other and all of those things but there
are ways to get to unity and it's funny
because when i was off the grid for
august
and i just spent time in the community
here and going to stores and doing baby
stuff and all of that it's like there
are good people everywhere and we all
know it and that's the thing that they
fear
the most
so what do you do what do you do you
fight back honestly and clearly and then
i think that
is attractive to people i really do so
here is uh governor ron desantis
responding to a little bit of charlie
crist nonsense on tucker carlson
this is his fifth decade running for
office he's a chameleon typical career
politician but you know tucker people
support me because i kept the state open
and protected their jobs charlie crist
wanted it locked down so that's not hate
in their heart they're just appreciative
that they had a governor who was
standing up for them parents around the
state support me
because we made sure schools were open
and we're working to make sure they get
education not indoctrination that's not
hate in their heart they're just
appreciative that they have a governor
that's fighting for them when he says he
claims that he wants to unify florida he
says he wants a florida for all and then
you condemn a majority of the people in
the state of florida give me a break and
the thing about what i've done is you
know we've done issues that people uh
across the spectrum have been able to
agree with and that's really what it's
all about it's not hating the other side
it's trying to have policies that a
majority can agree with
isn't that interesting and that tactic
telling the truth hey this is what i am
this is who i am this is what i stand
for this is what i've done as opposed to
those people who don't like me they have
hate in their hearts i have been around
an awful lot of desantis supporters and
a lot of the desantis team i've met a
whole bunch of really nice people some i
have some political disagreements with i
suppose um but if that that's one
message there's a clear message of
honesty and reality and then there's
just this sort of fake crazy message but
this crazy message is spreading
everywhere with the democrats and this
is what i need
uh i would say
my good democrat friends or any of you
who are still on the fence about what is
happening here where are the say because
i think most of you watching this you
probably you probably think of yourself
as somewhat conservative but but
centrist in a lot of ways the way that
we all sort of were in the 90s something
like that
and
we that is in stark contrast to what the
democrats of today have become
have become whether you're talking about
that crazy biden speech whether you're
talking about christ saying that half
the people in florida have hatred in
their hearts or here's this one this one
is this one is incredible
this is new york governor kathy hoechel
and this is a woman who nobody voted for
right she was installed after they got
rid of andrew cuomo she has become one
of the worst authoritarian lock down
vaccine
crazed politicians in america and listen
to what she's saying about basically
half the people in her state right now
and we're here to say
that the era
of trump
and zeldin and molinaro just jump on a
bus and head down to florida where you
belong okay get out of town get out of
town
because you don't re you don't represent
our values
you are not new yorkers
you are not new yorkers
try to imagine what an incredibly
hateful statement that is
i grew up in new york i spent most of my
adult life in new york until i moved to
la in 2013 and then to the free state of
florida in 2021
new york especially manhattan
metropolitan new york is
is exemplified
by all sorts of different people it is
the best living breathing example of
people from all walks of life with all
skin colors and ethnicities and foods
and languages can come together and live
in a good society together and we did it
for a long time these are the people who
are othering everybody they are doing
exactly what they accuse all of us of
doing and you know what's also
interesting about that when she says we
don't want the trump people here okay so
let's i'll even give her a little leash
fine you don't want those awful
deplorable ultra maga people but then
she also says those lee zeldin people
lee zeldin is the republican who is
running against her he's basically a
moderate republican whatever version of
that can exist in new york that's all he
is but he should not be in new york
either right and molinaro should not be
in new york either and only that she's
literally saying it to the constituents
you are not represented here we don't
want you here go to florida i would say
to those new yorkers
if you're conservative or
libertarian-leaning or you're just
somewhat sane or you don't want
government stepping all over you and you
don't want to be surrounded by those
morons yes come to florida come to
florida i actually think it would be a
pretty decent idea
ron desantis also
commented on those comments by kathy
hoechel and once again i think you'll
see a stark difference you have the
governor new york saying all republicans
need to leave the state just get on a
bus i mean how absurd is that
that you would say that but it shows the
mindset if you don't believe if you
don't bow down to what they want then
somehow you're a second-class citizen
that's very dangerous uh for a side you
know we're a diverse society we've got
people with a lot of different views and
we're proud to have been able to you
know have enacted a big agenda in
florida which we have strong support
across the state for on all our on all
our initiatives uh but but you can't go
down the road of saying these people
don't count what would happen i mean how
many people would be working in nypd or
the fire department if you kicked out
all the republicans from there it's
really really crazy that people are
saying stuff like this and so you know
in florida you know we try to embrace
policies uh you know that that anyone
can benefit from and and we want people
to do well uh regardless of you know how
they may register you know with a
particular political party and so we're
much different than new york in that
respect and i think we're a much freer
state as a result
kind of beautiful right like it's it's
obvious how much more do you need me to
comment on that like it's working in one
place and that's why people are moving
here and it's not working in places like
new york and california and that's why
people are fleeing but it's not just the
policies i guess this is the point
it's not just the policies right you
guys know all the stuff about the high
taxation and crushing the police
departments and all of that stuff it's
not just the policies it's also it's a
spirit
it's a spirit of freedom kathy hulchel
does not believe in freedom in any way
that i believe in freedom in any way
that ron desantis believes in freedom
and what she says basically is if you
don't believe what i believe if you
don't share the values that i share and
by the way her values will always shift
over time right because she doesn't she
doesn't believe in anything specific
what she believes in is the accumulation
of power so you will always do more this
is they will always do more to attain
power
and then you have that
in stark contrast to desantis hey i get
that there's diverse people out there i
get that not everyone's going to vote
for me but what i've tried to do is put
out the best policies for everybody and
see what happens like
it's becoming more and more obvious
that's my point and i and i'm trying to
link that back to hillary in 2016
their deplorables and now kathy hoechel
get out of my state charlie crist i
don't want you to vote for me these are
mainstream democrats where is anyone to
counter them where where is it where are
those people i will gladly put them on
uh
but you know there are some republicans
that are putting out a uh a positive
message here is tim scott now tim scott
excuse me
tim scott
a lot of talking today tim scott happens
to be a republican who is black and he
is from a southern state and he has
called all the worst things by the
so-called tolerant liberals and
progressives uh i'm not even going to
mention some of those things but you can
figure out what they call him uh well he
was recently asked um if there is
optimism to be found in our
situation take a look senator we've been
talking about the unity we felt in the
wake of 9 11 but here we are 21 years
later
is it a pipe dream to really think we
can get to some kind of unity
not at all shannon the good news is that
america always comes together after the
crisis i call it the aftermath mentality
brothers 9 11 the most unified time i've
seen in american history or you look at
south carolina after the mother emanuel
shooting
this estate came together and we had
african americans and whites and
hispanics all
at a bridge 20 000 strong showing the
unity of our state i believe that we are
the most exceptional people on earth and
we do unify after the crisis the
question is can we have the type of
leadership that unifies us without a
crisis
ah now that's it can we have leadership
that will unify us without a crisis like
do we need another 911 before we're
willing to all sit down at the table
again is that what we're going to force
to happen
because we won't do it otherwise when i
say we
i don't mean you watching this and i
don't mean me like i know we are willing
to do this and i know that we
are willing to live in a state with
people who are different as opposed to
the message that we're getting out of
kathy hotel etc etc
but what do we do about this so i think
what we have to do is keep figuring out
ways to welcome people into this this
new freedom movement because that's
that's the way we sell america that's
the way we save america is freedom is
what our ethos is freedom for you to
live the way you wish to live and what
is in stark contrast to that right now
well it is the woke thing it is the woke
thing that the democrats have brought in
and that the
big tech has ushered in and the cultural
machines and disney and all that stuff
has brought in we found this video over
the weekend uh this is director alan
hughes he did a great uh tupac shakura
documentary he did broken city with mark
wahlberg menace to society
he was asked about wokeness and what
it's doing to society and i thought this
was pretty great i brought up george
clooney right being the
traditional hollywood liberal right yeah
right i'm biracial so let's start with
that i can i can see both sides because
i i can't imagine
what he's thinking right now he's
probably at home like just shook and and
doesn't know what to say or do
for fear of being called something right
i'm talking about a liberal yeah because
locus has got so bad um that people are
digging up [ __ ] you said in the 70s
thinking of [ __ ] you said in the 90s not
even the 70s right
the culture always changes the lexicon
changes you gotta start judging people
on [ __ ] like that
then we gotta tear down all the statues
we gotta take mlk now yeah we gotta take
jfk down
so why i wanted to show this was here
you've got a documentarian guys working
with tupac like this is not a guy who
would be thought of he's certainly not a
conservative i don't think by any
stretch but the point is he's saying hey
libs it's even coming for you
it's even coming for you now yes were
there a whole bunch of us saying this a
long time ago yeah but but there's
something interesting going on there so
what do you do well we've got to crush
the wokeness right because they'll come
for what you said in the 70s and they'll
come for what you said in the 90s and
they'll come for what you said a week
ago
but you also have to figure out a way
and i can say this with with serious
clarity to figure out a better
relationship with social media i i can
tell you in the 10 days or so that i've
been back like
i'm first off i'm definitely trying to
tweet less that's the only one that i do
myself but it just all seems like fake
nonsense it just seems like fake
nonsense to to make you crazy and i have
no doubt that many of you that even if
you watch this you probably watch some
other things on youtube that are
endlessly causing you to feel angry
after i would challenge you i'll ask you
we'll look in the comments later it's
like do you feel angry after this show
or do you feel kind of lighter or that
you learn something or like maybe a
little more hopeful or something i hope
it's the latter right um but there is a
whole machine out there that the
algorithms are designed to keep you
hating and all of those things we all we
all know that that is the case i saw
this video by senator john kennedy about
what social media is doing to us and
it's doing to us and yet we keep
clicking
this also bothers me about social media
i think it has made
our society coarser
i think social media has lowered the
cost
of being an a-hole
and
i really regret that
i mean people say things on social media
that they would never say to another
person in person
i don't know what to do about that but i
don't think it's made
um i don't think it's made our society
better so in addition to in some
respects
being a killing feel for the truth
social media has also in many respects
made our people coarser
he's good social media is a killing
field for the truth i like that one that
is good so what do you do what do you do
well we got to crush the wokeness to the
best of our ability however you can try
to do that in your own life whether it's
getting your kids out of schools that
are teaching gender nonsense whether
it's joining a school board whether it's
moving from state to state you got to
crush that we have to rethink our
relationship with social media and maybe
get off some of these platforms and then
if there's a couple that maybe are
defending free speech a little better
i know a little something about locals
in rumble maybe be part of those but
then what else you have to be i think
actually one thing that would be nice
would be what if we actually made it
mainstream to be proud of this country
again you know that moment when george
bush was standing there in the rubble of
911
you feel it you feel like it was okay to
be american again you know when i see
american flags in my neighborhood here
and i'll tell you i see a lot more in
florida than i do in uh than i did in
california it's like it now me it
basically means you're a conservative
like why would a democrat
put up an american flag like if they
think it was fundamentally racist if
they think that it's systemically evil
if they think that all these things are
wrong and that fascism is here why would
you put the american flag up but i think
being proud of your country not asking
everything of your country but thinking
how you can be a better citizen
might be a key to this whole thing there
used to be a democrat who said something
like that
and so my fellow americans
ask not
what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
my fellow citizens of the world
ask not
what america will do for you
but what together we can do
for the freedom of man
far cry from what's going on on that
side of the aisle today but the point is
i think we can get back to that there is
still hope i'm in a weird way i'm more
hopeful now than ever before like the
more people that see this the more of
you that are paying attention that get a
little bit braver along the way
uh
maybe that's the way out of this thing
like the the shining horseman isn't
going to show up there'll be some good
ones along the way desantis will come
down along the way trump will come and
break the thing up years ago but
we need more we need more and uh and
that is why i'm hopeful that's why i do
this show i could not do it if i was not
hopeful right i would be endlessly
miserable and i'm not endlessly
miserable and i don't want to be
endlessly miserable uh but we can
inspire people by reminding them that
america is good and we're all in in this
together and that the founding of this
nation was built to be anti-racist as
opposed to the nonsense that they're
constantly pushing us on today this is
spectacular video
of the national anthem at the jets
ravens game on 9 11 yesterday and the
fans got in on it
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
ah
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
feels pretty good doesn't it and maybe
we don't need another 911 which of
course is what they were commemorating
right there to get back to that some
pride in the flag and pride in our
neighbors and our lives and and to get
the spirit that the founders
intended us to get
and all of that stuff so i think i made
a case today and how you perhaps
incorporate a little of that into your
own life like i get it's going to be
hard for us to sell this stuff for a
side that relentlessly doesn't want it
and algorithms that are weaponized
against us and a mainstream media that
wants us divided in a political class
that wants us stupid
but i still think we can do it
crazy i know guys it's me monday over at
the reuben report locals community
here's the one i put up today
eating bugs stops the weather
we're getting hundreds of responses over
there that's the next thing they're
pushing on us by the way if you didn't
know that the next thing coming with all
the climate nonsense is they're going to
want you to be eating bugs they're going
to keep eating the wagyu but they'll be
they'll be wanting you guys to eat the
bugs there a couple comments from the
locals community uh amy says thieving
and raping sounds like my eyeballs
review of watching the view yeah i'm
sorry we have to show you those things
and i won't show you any more charlie
crist
i can't promise and i'll show you more
things on the view because they do need
to be
exposed as such but
ek says the view sounds like nazis and
they don't even realize it well that's
the irony
when hochel says get out of the state
when uh sonny hostin demonizes half of
america when when hillary does this it
is it i don't mean to do the thing that
they do which is compare everything to
nazis and hitler and all those things
but when you keep oh repeatedly time and
time again take a set of people
put blame on them that they do not blame
accuse them of things that they that
they are not guilty of well that is the
tactic that authorizes people and then
when you fuel that with algorithms and
you fuel that with clicks and the awful
mainstream media and everything else
i've talked about here you think you
could get people to hate people in an
unwarranted fashion i think maybe you
could homeschool mama says wish we could
get some of that pride in america back
in the mainstream hey i don't know if we
can get it back in the mainstream but
the mainstream is crumbling and these
types of things are more important
what's more important would you rather
have all of joe rogan's audience
believing the things that i've talked
about here today or would you rather
have all of the people who watch the
view well guess what rogan's audience is
way way bigger uh and we're blowing up
across things too by the way uh i really
i you know my feelings i want you guys
if you're watching on youtube please
jump over to rumblerumble.com slash
reuben report subscribe hit that bell
and join us at reubenreport.locals.com
where i can directly get in touch with
you and i share baby pictures each
morning so far and uh and good stuff uh
by the way my full interview with jared
kushner is available across everything
right now the reaction to it has been
really really good you know people don't
know much about jared right they know he
married ivanka and he was trump's uh
advisor and he was often standing in the
back of the room but you never really
heard him speak this is a very very rare
uh full hour plus long interview with
the guy
nothing was off the table he said i
could ask him absolutely anything we did
not edit it we never edit our videos but
we did not edit i think you get to see a
little insight
he says something interesting
about how the machine just exists it
just exists it existed before him it's
going to exist after him and how can you
play in that game when you have a chance
to hopefully do something good i think
that's partly what i'm trying to do i
think it's probably what you're trying
to do anyway we do not have a cold
clothes for you because i thought that
the 911
uh event right there at uh the jets game
was good enough so uh that's it i've
enjoyed this monday show it wasn't
what's not the funniest show i've ever
done
not the funniest show but
will be will be funnier you thought it
was the funny show i've ever done
alright guys see you tomorrow